oh my god is here guess what movie
premiered man Twilight Oh what is going
on YouTube guess what Twilight is oh
well that was really a [ __ ] if you
haven't guessed already uh uh hey
Twilight and you know what I already
know what you thinkin ladies you hate
Twilight cuz it's a chick flick no I
hate it because it's such donkey balls
there are so many things wrong with this
series I don't even know where to begin
so you already know what it is
LG awesome let's get it people stop
telling me I'll appreciate it more if I
read the damn book if I can't watch two
hours of it why would I read 300 pages
of the damn thing how because it's
better you have to observe it that way
very good sure you're telling me I have
to observe and get closer to the [ __ ] I
hate more in order to love it huh well
here's a piece of beauty go ahead and
smell it a little closer you'll like it
more yeah yeah get that [ __ ] out of my
face
that is exactly like the dumbest advice
on this Puerto Rican personal trainer
David there's only one way for you to
lose weight you have to be short I've
sort of said being skinny bet is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life
[ __ ] I've been visualizing myself
skinny white bull Rico suave looking ass
well haha visualized upon your ass back
to Puerto Rico why the hell do these
vampires glitter in the daylight
somebody explain that [ __ ] to me let me
get this straight so you're telling me
that instead of bursting into flames now
when they hit the Sun they turn into a
gay disco ball man let's pick you know
these mother even garlic bread drink you
hold water and go to church do you know
why I watched the first Twilight movie
because my girl at the time made me go
do you know why we broke up because she
made me watch Twilight so I'd like the
movie it was good yeah no and it's over
between us get out for those of you who
have not seen any of the Twilight movies
let me summarize for you in a few
seconds don't watch the movie
just watch this turn into a vampire no
tell me - a vampire
no tell me - that I'm sorry listen to me
till tomorrow now because of this movie
there have been some unreal expectations
rested upon man why can't you be more
like Edward vampire I'm sorry
I can't carry you on my bed while
climbing up a damn rain forest I'm sorry
when the Sun is my skin I don't look
like a jacket at a princess wardrobe I
tan like a rice farmer
you want me to stop a car with my bare
hands yeah I do better
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon the way
cuz I'm doing [ __ ] I'm not judging it
because it's a love story I'm judging
this because it sucks ass I actually
attended to watch the second one it was
just as bad if not worse than the first
one so let me go ahead and summarize
that one for you real quick
I love you I'm leaving I'm sad I can
sound like the wolf boy I'm bad I used a
wolf boy do you turn into a vampire you
sure yes I'm Snow
hey check it out you do so a good friend
of mine is actually getting married this
Sunday and I'm not going to be able to
make it to his wedding and so I just
wanted to give a little quick shout out
to him he's been a friend of mine since
God knows when since we were probably
like 6 or 7 years old and he's getting
married on Sunday but I have work up
here so I can't really make it so shout
out to both Sam and Jennifer uh Sam has
been one of my closest friends since I
was a little kid before I actually even
started doing comedy and stuff like that
he's always been a part of the backbone
that has allowed me to pursue my dreams
no matter where you go online never
forget those people that have helped you
along the way because when I was younger
I didn't have a lot of friends he's
actually one of those friends that stuck
around that believed in me when I
thought I was like a piece of [ __ ] so uh
so for those of you out there that have
worked hard and have a lot of success
don't forget all those people that have
helped you along the way because without
them you wouldn't be where you're at so
Sam you're my boy I love you very much
and I'm sorry I can't be there for your
wedding man but when I come back I
celebrate it up and so everything that I
have right now you want a little piece
of it man because you helped me went out
and believed in myself so
ha with text messages with the huh what
was it I actually attempted to watch the
second one it was worse if not just as
bad as the first one so let me oh I just
burped